good afternoon and welcome to today's
presentation on how to use machen in
clinical practice we will go through an
overview of Megan and then some
searching and navigation tips we will
also summarize some ways to incorporate
Megan in the clinical genetics process
let's start by showing you the Megan
homepage in our URL you can also find us
by googling NIH Majan Megan is a free
website where you can find information
about genetic phenotypes aggregated from
many authoritative sources so instead of
checking if there is a gene reviews for
a condition then opening in your browser
to read what form M has to say and then
go into clinical trials to look for
relevant clinical trials for your
patients you can come to imagine and in
one page see a summary of the
information each of these resources has
on the condition and links to those
resources so imagine you will find
information on Mendelian disorders
pharmacogenetic responses complex
diseases with a genetic component and
clinical features each measure and
record has a disease name the preferred
name is nomad CT which is the source of
disease names most electronic medical
records use so it should facilitate
incorporation in clinical settings you
will also see other attributes of the
disease such as alternate names from
different sources with their identifier
z' again the purpose being to easily
integrate match and in electronic
medical systems in your hospital or
clinic you can see causative genes mode
of inheritance in disease descriptions
along with the list of clinical features
you get access to patient oriented
resources like genetics home reference
guard and MedlinePlus in the same page
provides access to actionable
information such as practice guidelines
clinical trials.gov a list of genetic
tests for the disease in the GTR in the
list of variants in the causative genes
in green bar so these are the resources
you can find in machen and then some
more
so instead of opening it up to check the
latest publications from PubMed or
searching professional guidelines for
guidelines of professional societies for
guidelines you can find them all imagine
okay so now let's go over how to use
Majan this is the imagine home page
there are links here to documentation
that describes in detail what Megan is
and how to use it
Megan serves as the phenotype source for
submissions to clinvar in GTR for
information on how to use it for this
purpose please look at the presentation
available from this home page I want to
point out that Megan store's
professional guidelines and we provide
the link to all guidelines from here we
currently have 455 professional
guidelines that range from practice
guidelines from medical professional
societies like ACMG and SGC and NH CCN
all the way to FDA drug labels for the
drugs with pharmacogenetic information
imagine is a resource for you and we
want to be useful to you so we welcome
your feedback and if you see we are
missing a guideline please contact us
and we will add it there is also a link
to the FTP site which has files with our
data that you can download for free you
can search imagine by entering your
search term in the search box you can
use things like these names drug
responses genes even Oh mum numbers and
HBO IDs one feature of madryn is that
you can search for conditions by a
clinical feature we draw from data from
HBO and mmm in soon we will be adding
orphanet as well to strengthen these
disease to clinical feature
relationships so if you search for
arachnid actally the top result is the
record for the clinical feature but you
also have a link at the very top of the
page if you want to see all the Z's that
have arachnid actually as a clinical
feature so clicking on the clinical
feature record
you get the preferred name whenever
available you will see an image from any
GRI elements of morphology a definition
with a source in this case it's HPL
below that you get a list of conditions
with a clinical feature again these come
from mappings between omen and hbl when
you hover over the condition you get a
summary of the disease and the link that
will take you to the full record for the
disease you can see in this example for
Marfan syndrome okay so in the Advanced
Search located just below the search box
machen allows you to search by
specifying multiple parameters like
clinical features genes chromosomal
locations mode of inheritance or umem
numbers for example you can specify two
different clinical features by selecting
clinical feature in the search builder
then type a term and click the show
index list to select from a set of
predefined terms you can add the gene or
anything else you know about your
patient and then click search now this
is a search result page which lists the
diseases that fit your parameters this
page shows you the summary of the
disease so you can see if that is the
disease you are looking for before you
even open a page you also see various
useful links at the bottom a link to
list of tests in GTR for this condition
link to a list of variants on the
causative genes in clinvar link to the
gene record in NCBI gene database link
to almond record and a link to gene
reviews when available now let's look at
what a disease record looks like in
Metron this is the disease record for
Marfan syndrome these pages are along so
you just scroll down to see all the
information or you can use the table of
contents on the right hand side to jump
to the section of interest view at the
top you have the disease
name in synonyms mode of inheritance
causative genes identifier with links to
sources like Coleman and orphanet then
you have a list of descriptions from
available sources like gene reviews on
genetics home reference HBO or human
phenotype ontology typically medical
genetic summaries and pharmgkb have
definitions for pharmacogenetic
phenotypes NCI the National Cancer
Institute for oncology phenotypes or any
other resource with disease information
we are able to access for um you also
have links to go look at the full page
for the disease from the source so you
have one disease description at the top
and then if there are descriptions from
other sources they will be list listed
in the additional descriptions section
along with links to those sources so
below that you have a list of clinical
features for this condition again from
data aggregators from mm and HBO when
you hover over the clinical feature you
see a description in two links one for
the full record as you saw before for
arachnid actally and want to get a list
of diseases with the clinical feature
now you can use this list of clinical
features to guide your evaluation of
your patient you know that you have the
term hierarchy these may come from NCBI
or this way for mesh or or finatus
labeled below are the professional
guidelines in suggested articles these
are manually curated by our staff then
you see a list of recent publications
from PubMed categorized by etiology
diagnosis therapy prognosis clinical
prediction guidelines and systematic
reviews basically you get a PubMed
search right on the mesh on page to
supplement all this information the
right-hand side of each page provides
links to even more resources based on
conditions and genes for example you
have links to genetic tests registered
in GTR by test
methodology or the co-option links to
clinical trials.gov
for a list of clinical trials for the
condition you are researching links to
molecular resources like the omen gene
pages in clinvar links to gene reviews
when available and medical genetics
summaries for pharmacogenetic records
links to PubMed health for information
on the disease and clinical features
links to consumer resources like card
and ghr to educate your patient and
their families and these are just to
name a few merchants serves as the
phenotype source for GTR and clinvar
this enables us to standardize disease
names across tests from all labs as well
as standardized phenotypes in variant
interpretation in clinvar all our data
is freely available for download as
mentioned before because Megan
aggregates phenotype data from different
sources and preserves the source
identifiers it can be integrated in
electronic medical record software to
standardize genetic disease names in the
community hospital systems can use NCBI
API to tailor views of the genetic
information for their users at point of
care in the note about data updates in
Megan Megan processes updates from
sources as they become available not all
sources have the same schedule to
release updates so we process them when
we get them mostly in automated
workflows so in summary you can use
mention to research a phenotype and
access all resources from one page it
can be your one-stop shop for genetic
disease information it can help suggest
conditions that feed the cluster of
clinical features for a patient it
provides the list of clinical features
you can use to evaluate a patient for a
suspected diagnosis you can access
practice guidelines for a condition as
well as therapeutic recommendations for
drug responses based on genotypes from
various professional societies links to
available genetic tests to confirm diet
Yelling's to clinvar to help with
variant interpretation of a test result
links to consumer resources for the
patients and families we want to hear
from you about how to be more useful so
please contact us with your feedback in
any questions you may have at the email
on this slide please note that it's
Meghan and their score help and please
follow us on Twitter for updates thank
you for your attention and enjoy Meghan
there's a couple of questions in here
now
Izzie fetch so this is one of the
utilities is this enabled for Meghan
records and I think the particular
question has to do with whether the Floy
certainly you can get the summary
because it's an entree but I don't know
whether you can get the full XML record
for imagine or not yeah and we can
confirm that and put that in the
follow-up document so another question
is do these medgen records link to gos
data for complex diseases so for example
what are the significant snips
associated with a particular disease so
right now no Megan does not link to G
was data we do link to clean var which
has the G was data there Melissa
Landrum chimed in and said that a key
fetch in fact is not available for
medgen so you're not going to be able to
get the full records that way for Megan
another question is does legend use an
ontology like sno-med CT yes so sno-med
CT is what we select as our preferred
names so we have the sno-med CT
preferred name as well as the
identifiers so yes and Jennifer Lee asks
could you fetch be enabled for Megan
well hopefully yes so it is a matter of
you know getting the resources to do it
but could it be navels yes in the future
and thank you for that suggestion I will
definitely put it on the list okay
here's another question does the end of
national guidelines clearing
affect the curated guidelines mentioned
the funding to support the national
guideline Clearinghouse has not been
secured beyond July 16 2018 right so for
the professional guidelines we do have
the ones from the clearinghouse so the
ones that are going to be archived we
will have them available but they are
not our only source of guidelines so we
will have them
we will have guidelines from other
sources as well since they are not our
only source I'm hoping they doesn't
affect us all too much okay thanks
another question is it common for
hospitals medical centers to integrate
medgen in their health records so are
part of the effort called open info
button so we do have every likely to
have our data available and like I said
this is a free resource we are at NCBI
so everything we have is free now that I
know of there hasn't been any hospital
that has integrated this information
into their system so if you do know of
one I would love to know about it but we
do have everything it's freely available
so any hospital would be able to
integrate it and then depending on how
hospitals or clinics have that
information because we know some
hospitals might might have information
based on HBO IDs or maybe even sno-med
CT Zoar orphanet IDs or whatever it is
we do have all of that information to to
make the the integration smooth and easy
okay thanks everybody I don't see any
question any more questions so let's go
ahead and close the webinar is there
anything else that you need it's Adriano
okay so ok thanks everybody